I get a message from a friend of mine who says that while he was listening to
the show,
we were talking about something and then the ads for that thing started showing
up.
Yeah.
Oh God.
It's a,
it's Fong from my plastic cell.
He said you guys were talking about slouching with the avant today and this
popped up on his feet just now.
I never googled it before.
And it's some fucking alarm that goes off.
Like when you slouch forward,
have you seen us things?
You glue them on you.
I've been getting an ad for that too.
Oh,
you have some IP is random coincidence could be that.
Or it could be targeting Joe Rogan listeners do the way it works.
So they found out that we were listening to,
they could just be going,
I mean maybe that,
but like there's a large audience here so they could just be going after like,
oh right.
But do you think like with Adam Green,
she said the other day that that's happening again,
talking about,
he was talking about Toyota trucks and then all of a sudden is Google ads
started showing up.
Toyota Tacomas and he and he was like,
dude,
he goes,
they're listening and the robots are listening.
So one's listed,
but they're also looking for like key terms and stuff like that.
But they're listening to your phone as you're having a conversation you think?
Yes,
I have a few instances.
I took screenshots because I was,
it was happening.
It happened three,
three consecutive weeks.
I touched something.
I literally held the object in my hand and within 12 hours I was getting an ad
for it.
Maybe your magic bro.
It's very strange.
One of them I have with list,
they're so weird.
It was like,
how the fuck am I getting an ad for this thing now?
I've never even seen this.
I've never talked about it to anybody.
I didn't tell anybody I was holding it.
Yeah,
you got to look for it.
Always be careful of like this idea that,
you know,
because sometimes things are just a coincidence.
And this idea that there's some grand conspiracy when it could be easily
explained by coincidence,
but the thing that Adam said,
he said it,
he goes,
man,
I never fucking Google Toyota trucks.
Is that a good,
uh,
I was trying to get that really not bad.
Not that good.
A little British.
Hey Mike.
Um,
but he was saying that,
uh,
they start popping up right after the podcast immediately.
So if that's the case,
they had to be listening to his podcast or they are listed one of them's list
because it's a,
you have a large audience,
someone from there's listen to it live.
Right.
And then they're just like,
dude,
they launched those at yeah,
but it has to get on his Google feed.
Yeah.
You think they spoil more fucking crime and stuff if they're listening?
Nah,
don't make money spoiling crime,
Bro.
I'm like,
you make money selling trucks.
I don't know.
I mean,
I,
I feel like for sure when I Google something and starts popping up,
we know that.
But that seems normal.
Dude,
if you call my phone right now,
because I've been looking at dodge vipers,
it anything I click on dodge vipers pop up even on ads on Instagram.
Real.
Yeah.
They just want to,
they're just trying to get you,
they like,
when I look at houses in certain markets pop up.
It's weird.
They know.
Some mother fuckers look at and spend some money.
Yeah.